Mind Your Decisions. I am Presh Talwalkar.
In a rectangle, two line segments are drawn
dividing the rectangle into four regions.
Three of the regions have areas of 1, 3 and 4.
What is the area of the 4th region?
The diagram is not drawn to scale.
Pause the video if you like to give this problem a try,
and when you are ready, keep watching to learn how to solve this problem
We get started by focusing on these two triangles.
These two angles are equal to each other
because of vertical angles.
Next, these two angles are equal to each other
because of alternate interior angles.
This is because opposite sides of rectangle are parallel to each other.
Consequently, these two triangles have two equal angles,
which means all three angles are equal and these triangles are similar.
As the areas are in ratio of 4:1,
their sides would in a ratio of 2:1.
That's because the area is proportional to side length squared.
Suppose the top triangle has a side length of a,
its corresponding side length in the bottom triangle must be 2a.
If the top triangle has a height of h,
then the bottom triangle would has a height of 2a.
Consider the area of the top triangle,
it would be a times h all over 2,
that would be equal to 1.
This means ah is equal to 2.
Now go back to the rectangle.
We can solve for one of its side length.
It would be equal to h plus 2h.
Therefore, this side length would be 3h.
The other side length is 2a.
Therefore, the area of this entire rectangle
would be 2a multiplies by 3h,
which is equal to 6ah.
Since ah is equal to 2, 6ah would be equal to 12.
We can then solve the problem quite easily.
Three of the areas in the rectangle are 1, 3 and 4,
that means the last area would be 12 minus 1 minus 3 minus 4,
and that's equal to 4,
and that's the missing area.
Thanks for making Mind Your Decisions one of the best channels on YouTube.
As always, thanks for watching. Thanks for your support.